I haven't uploaded anything to this
YouTube channel in about a month I
thought I would make this video to talk
about mental health men's mental health
in particular hopefully make some sort
of change within the world welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and Movie
Channel
[Music]
so let's talk about where I've been for
the last month very briefly
to cut it short I have been depressed
and being depressed is something that I
have
had in my life for the better part of 15
17 18 years
so pretty much most of my life I have
had depression in some form this stems
from childhood trauma
um involving things that happened online
when I was 12 13 years old and then from
that bullying uh within school I'm not
going to go into specifics about what
happened with regards to that because I
put that to bed I've gone to therapy and
I'm now reconciled with that
to the point where I now I know it
wasn't my fault it's not something that
I dwell on anymore but the residual
depression is still something
um that remains because I believe
wholeheartedly the Depression was
something that was formed as a coping
mechanism
so when I feel attacked when I feel like
things aren't going the way they should
that I repress into myself and that is
essentially the depressed state that I'm
in where I I don't look after myself I
don't talk to anyone and I become a
shell of the man that I usually am now
this is a very important topic to me
depression and mental health I feel like
a lot of people I speak to men in
particular now obviously women do have
these issues but I want to talk
specifically about men because I as a
male
um and something I want to talk to you
about afterwards it's closer to home to
me and I want to talk about
how it is for me I think mental health
and talking about mental health and
talking about how you feel
with anyone doesn't matter who it is
is vitally important now I want to
publicly hear thank Jay because when I
was going through it over the last month
or so Jay instantly noticed now we I've
never met Jay
in real life
I first joined this channel because
because I was a Stargate fan I found his
videos
and then I messaged him just saying do
you want a Discord server because I
noticed you haven't got a community and
he said yeah
we then started talking he then invited
me to join Sidetrack now we're here now
we're friends a relationship that's been
formed essentially through a camera
it's amazing because he instantly knew
that something was wrong now me being me
I said no no there's nothing wrong
I'm absolutely fine but there was
something wrong I was depressed
um and it never really needs to be a
reason why you're depressed it just
happens I say I say there wasn't a
reason but it was
it was very it was in hindsight it's a
very stupid thing to think about
but people some people on in the
comments have basically said you're not
a real sci-fi fan and then that played
on my mind it was one comment realist
really it was one comment I can't
remember who made it but someone said
you're not a real sci-fi fan that played
on my mind
I then
started doubting whether I should be on
this channel whether or not I was I was
a real sci-fi fan whether or not
anything I had to say had any value and
I just started doubting myself my place
on this channel and where I should be
should I should I quit should I leave
should I should I stay what should I do
and that
that kind of Circle of thought wouldn't
stop essentially so I stopped uploading
and I stopped talking to anyone but fair
play to Jay he messaged me and he knew
there was something wrong we spoke about
it and I I did start to feel about feel
better about it but it also got me
thinking
about mental health in general and how
fickle some of our minds can be because
the littlest comment can often trigger
something that to you it's a comment
that maybe throw away maybe ingest
but to someone else that could be the
difference between them waking up the
next morning or not and I'm not
suggesting that
whoever made that comment could have
caused the worst thing possible what I'm
what I'm trying to get at is when you're
in that mindset when you have depression
the littlest thing can set you off and
that's something we need to talk about
as a community as a society because at
some point it's going to happen and
someone is not going to wake up the next
morning now this leads me on to a
personal story it was within the last
week the third anniversary of my dad's
death now the reason my dad died was
because he had committed suicide this is
something that has messed with my mind
we didn't have the greatest relationship
growing up
um I didn't see him for a very very long
time it was only when my daughter was
born I reached out and we started
forming a relationship again and we
started to see each other regularly and
we started to build
that farthest on relationship again I
moved away I now live in the Midlands
but I'm originally from the south of the
UK but yeah I got a phone call
from my sister just in an evening
I was playing a game I was probably
playing RuneScape I got a phone call and
the first words I heard were dad's dead
and I immediately
said what
she told me again dad's dead now we we
thought that perhaps
he had accidentally taken
um an overdose on the tablet so he was
on for
something wrong with his teeth I don't
know what it was but it quickly became
apparent that he had intentionally taken
his life by grinding up the tablets and
drinking himself into Oblivion so that
he didn't feel the pain when he
eventually passed
and this is something that he would have
done because he felt pain
in his everyday life he felt
I guess that he was alone he probably
felt that mistakes he had made in his
past had caught up with him perhaps
perhaps he felt that
there was no one that he could turn to
when he was in a dire situation and this
is what I want to talk about I want
people to be able to talk to each other
about these kinds of things and it's
something that I need to start doing as
well when you start to feel depressed
when you have any niggling concerns when
you have anything that you think is
going to trigger a panic attack a mental
breakdown oppression if you start having
thoughts of suicide or that you don't
belong here or that you don't have any
worth in this world you need to then
look at that realize that that is a
problem because that is not a normal way
to think you need to tell someone tell
your partner tell your mum tell your dad
to tell your best friend tell literally
anyone because that could be the
difference between you waking up
tomorrow
or not and I've been in the same
situation my dad has been in where I
have attempted to take my own life that
is the reason why I have
this tattoo this is a semicolon
um I I saw a post
years and years ago about what the
meaning of a semicolon is and why you
would have a semicolon as a tattoo
and I thought it was really good and it
really spoke to me so the reason I have
the semicolon is because in
writing a semicolon is something that a
writer can use to either end a sentence
or choose to carry on so it's a little
bit different to a full stop you can
either end it right there or you can
carry on the sentence and it's a choice
you can end it or you can carry it on
and that speaks to me in a in a very
profound way so I got this tattoo as a
reminder that I chose to carry on and
I'm not suggesting that you go out and
get a tattoo as well as a reminder you
you don't have to do that this is
something that I did but talking to
people
talking to absolutely anyone about what
you're going through
I think is vitally important now I'm
going to leave some links in the
description to some Charities you might
want to donate to them they're going to
be men's mental health Charities there's
one called calm that I donate to which
is the campaign against living miserably
which is a men's mental health charity
you've also got mind I'll leave a link
to that as well um but it might be a
local charity nearer to you that you'd
like to donate to and if you do want to
then feel absolutely free this video
wasn't meant to be give me all your
money give it to charity and
and things like that because it that's
secondary yes that would help other
people
but you need to help yourself you need
to you need to look after number one
you need to look after what's up here
because you matter